my mother about you sorry thank you what
else would I do with myself
hi I'm Eric Singer eric is a dialect
coach who helps actors with their
accents in film and television let's
look at some clips
southern accent Brad Pitt inglorious
basterds their left foot soldiers have a
jew-hating mass-murdering maniac and
they need to be destroyed
Tennessee accents and southern accents
in general have something called goose
fronting sad good which is that the
vowel in words like goose jew-jew
humanity humanity cruel we will be cruel
to the Germans his fronter in the mouth
so jus humanity cruel he doesn't really
get that it's what I liked here Nigerian
accent Will Smith concussion if you
continue to deny my work the world will
deny my work
Smith is playing a real person here
that's all I am Bennet Omalu who has a
somewhat Americanized Nigerian accent
that Oh Will Smith playing me Smith
doesn't seem to be going for a malas
voice so much as do the truth kind of
generalized Nigerian or African accent
the truth listen to those th sounds in
this this is bigger than they are they
should be dentalized
this day this is bigger than they are
impersonation of Truman Capote Philip
Seymour Hoffman Capote I know ain't
you've handed in the final scene when
the bellhop told me I had a phone call
this is just amazing in every way his
particular vocal quality and mannerisms
are just like Capote's I think
journalism can be good but I don't think
creative writing can be good the accent
is dead-on perfect here with my dead
father Joe Caputi and the accents
totally integrated going to see my
mother died it's integral to the
character and what the actor is doing as
the character he had quite a lot to say
about us Boston accent Michael Keaton
spotlight this is our town Jimmy
everybody knew something was going on
and no one did a thing he's going for a
Boston accent that has one of the
stereotypical markers which is a lot god
hot foul he says on one time come on and
he says on the next
if something was going on he doesn't do
that rounding on confirmation from take
a confirmation confirmation confirmation
you should we got to put it into it
polish accent kate winslet jobs that you
told her you weren't going to pay for
harvard this is really good for the most
part thank you
a thing that she doesn't quite get is
the oral posture her mouth is very open
again maybe theater training the more
you open your mouth the more sound comes
out it's a little thing have a look at
johanna Hoffman's jaw all software
developers it's a much closer joy it's
much higher the less space between the
teeth extremely easy to use
look at Kate Winslet's but what you make
isn't supposed to be the best part of
you much more open Meryl Streep and
Sophie's Choice
check out her job take care then love
her very very good to me
Belfast accent Tom Cruise far and away
grace is it she's a dancer in the
burly cute she's my sister you know I'm
sure this could have been better I know
the actor probably wasn't given enough
time to prepare that's enough of a
sounds in like we get to see it like my
shirt and hat did you say you like my
hat keep going all over the place like
sometimes they're close sometimes
they're just say it Tom Cruise hardeneth
French accent Joseph gordon-levitt the
Walk This Day is going up go back to the
hotel if I'm not back in five hours look
for me to pull a stitch yes sir this is
pretty good there are definitely things
that could be improved here's a good
thing listen to the vowel in stop they
just ride the never stuff those human
pretty dead-on
she might pull out his are sounds here
as being inconsistent sometimes he's got
a French to uvular the scale the scale
sometimes a more American sounding rep
they just right they just right but
people are inconsistent that's real that
th sound and that is
she's my dream he nails it and it's too
easy that's hard for a French speaker Oh
idris elba mandela long walk to freedom
my lord it is not i but the government
that should be put in the dock this is a
great job
Elba does a lot to capture Mandela's
particular vocal characteristics and
mannerism and placement rich
I hope to live for he's actually got a
little bit of a retracted a pulled back
tongue rude listen to the word prepared
I am prepared as opposed to prepared I
am prepared we call that the square
lexical set it should be a monophthong
for Mandela and Xhosa accents generally
whereas Elba makes it a different I
prayed north guilty
southern accent Nicolas Cage Conair I
got nothing in common with the end with
you they were the same
it's my daughter's birthday today I
don't know what happened to the actors
prep here my first thought would be this
doesn't really hit any of the marks
southern accents have vowel breaking in
words like creep and freak there's
somehow managed to get every creep and
freak in the universe which means that's
a little wiggle crate and freak creep
and freak also a foul and weird like
playing only this one play should start
lower you're not hearing any of that
Wyoming Texas accents Jake Gyllenhaal
Heath Ledger
Brokeback Mountain you being a Mexico
Jack twist cuz out here what they got in
Mexico for boys like you here yes I've
been in Mexico Gyllenhaal nails his
Wyoming accent here listen to the vowel
in 1 & 1 so it's all the way back in his
mouth I did once I did once you can also
hear it in a couple of high altitude
folks couple of high out to do
once or twice a year I loved his
performance Here I am joking the
characters tightness and repression and
kind of struggle with himself is
mirrored in his posture boom the newer
look the way his jaw and his lips are
held tight all the time you can even see
him listening through that posture why
don't you let me be though English
accent
Kevin Costner Robin Hood
Prince of Thieves the chef calls us
outlaws but I say we are free so this is
like the paradigm of bad movie accents
this is the one everybody brings up for
good reason and faced with the price
where it may be dear he can't make up
his mind whether to leave the ARS in or
take them out he's more powerful than 10
hired soldiers nothing's right here then
I say we can win Creole accent from
Sierra Leone Leonardo DiCaprio Blood
Diamond
you get full pammie force for them and
get one more dead body instead of
aeroplane way full with grenade launcher
DiCaprio is speaking a West African
Creole here called Creole
Jane Goldman at least and go pay me huh
all rotten air Caden no rotten AKM can't
stand government true against then
government true it's a creditable job
but it's no fine huh it's a little
marred by some West Indian intonation
are you Chris otherwise it's pretty good
are you Chris David or yellow whoa Selma
but we shall be victorious in our quest
David's not doing an impersonation
it's more of an evoke ation which means
he's just suggesting this very familiar
voice listen to how much of his vocal
range Martin Luther King jr. actually
uses a man die when he refuses to stand
up for justice and compare it to David a
yellow not quite the same Baltimore
accent Idris Elba the wire we're not
gonna bring that corner up in
here you hear me
there's two volume up the truth business
this is amazing Elmo was working on this
accent for years one thing this axe that
doesn't have is a really interesting
Baltimore specific african-american
pronunciation of words like to you what
do you do follow to what about you but
you can hear from other actors in the
same show who are actually Baltimore
natives listen to prop Joe naylet my
nephew my nephew Japanese accent Mickey
Rooney Breakfast at Tiffany's
we have a pee made let this happen
vintage New York City accent Daniel
day-lewis
Gangs of New York I want you to go out
there you nobody else punished it's
always tough to do a historical accent
do you go for absolute accuracy at the
risk of alienating the audience and
making it inaccessible may have
misgivings but don't go believe in magic
and I think he walks the line
brilliantly here the tip of his tongue
hits a different place hits his teeth
which is characteristic of a New York
accent
tell me tell me tell me this charge does
it sit on easy with you he also gets a
lot of nasality into the accent when in
the heaven's name you're talking about
still maintains a lot of color and
expression help yourself to some decent
meat on the way out Scottish accent no
Gibson Braveheart and I see Oh army of
my countrymen dear and defiant security
you know I think maybe Gibson gets a bad
rap for this performance yeah it does
slip out why does it go but when it's on
it's pretty good for example fight and
you may die run and you love that's
pretty good I give you thanks
Russian accent Viggo Mortensen Eastern
Promises if you can prove baby was his
and Goethe was in that age that is
statutory rape
yeah Mortensen does a pretty creditable
job here but please it doesn't feel
quite integrated it's a little general
for political reasons it's not that the
sounds are off they're all pretty good
okay it just feels a little stiff and a
little careful the accent hasn't quite
settled in yet thank you not like a real
person speaking and then when you're
talking their mouth
afrikaans accent Matt Damon Invictus
please mr. president
it plays complete sense to me in the bus
on the way to the stadium
nobody talks damon prepped really well
for this role and it's just a great job
on an accent that's usually really hard
for Americans there's always something
to pick on listen to the line that has
chosen and no in it something I've
chosen when we all know nails that vowel
the first time something I've chosen not
so much the second time when we all know
Paraguay and accent jon voight anaconda
never look in the eyes of those you
killed they will haunt you forever I
have no idea what that accent was I know
Kate Blanchet The Aviator
he's equalities but it's all tied up
inside the body so this is a great
avocational Katharine Hepburn's
particular idiolect if I had to quibble
with it I'd say that Blanchette relies
really strongly on Hepburn's Tambor and
intonation your honor
yeah she doesn't quite have the posture
she has a very open jaw perhaps from her
theater training if your death you must
own up to it I supposed to the sort of
high tide and slightly forward jaw that
Katharine Hepburn had women and men
simply are not the same man got these
friends with women how they're just not
the same English accent Angelina Jolie
Maleficent I really felt quite
distressed not receiving an invitation
so Julie's going for us like the
old-fashioned very posh English accent
here yeah yeah what we'd call received
pronunciation and she does a great job
of it oh dear listen to the way she says
the words royalty royalty nobility
nobility gentry gentry and those short
ending a sounds you won't really hear
that in English accents anymore how
quaint
Russian accent john malkovich rounders
and in my club I will splish the port
whenever the I please
is wolf you have left in the morning so
Russian speaking English will sometimes
stick a little yet sound in alligator
loved and what Malkovich does here is
something that no Russian speaker
speaking English would actually do which
is palatalized everything the way
Malkovich says this ain't cool my cool
is over-enthusiastic you'll never hear
that from an actual Russian speaker
London accent Renee Zellweger Bridget
Jones's Diary the greatest book of our
time one of the top 30
music oral posture these things are all
going really really well thank you
she does lateral plosion on words like
gentleman gentleman that's exploding the
T sounds straight into the L sound when
it's difficult for a lot of people
gentlemen gently gentlemen it's that
estuary English accent that she's going
for with a character properly German
accent Brad Pitt seven years in Tibet
the one raising their flags and honor
the Chinese don't deserve this could be
better listen to the words have you have
the entire Palace in a panic and kind
kind of difficult in the Glass House no
in German the consonants at the ends of
words are D voiced and this carries over
into English so weird like have you have
the entire Palace is gonna have a sound
at the end of weird like kind kind of
difficult is gonna have more like a
sound at the end so half and kind which
is really hard for a German to do
speaking english belfast accent brad
pitt snatch brings the filler size of
you unless they're trying to say
something they're talking right by right
of you I wanna Catamounts kind of weeds
Belfast English can be really hard for
American ears to understand the abuzz
about hey sorry listen the vowels in the
words car she got a car you got a car
which was just great contrast that with
in the devil's own when he says see
and sleep there is no more peaceful way
I want to see and he just doesn't have
it New York City accent he Fletcher the
dark night but I know the truth there's
no going back you've changed things
forever this is a weird idiosyncratic
American accent you for a weird
idiosyncratic character complete I love
the way he's able to maintain his accent
even with this weird tongue flicking
outa gesture that it does this part of
the character
English accent Keanu Reeves Bram
Stoker's Dracula I know where the Boston
sleeps my bottom there I've seen many
strange things already bloody wolves
chasing me through some blue infernos
how southern English accents are
non-rhotic you leave the R sound out
after a vowel in a word like inferno
blue inferno he can't make up his mind
whether to do it or not I will give it
my full attention
vintage California accent Daniel
day-lewis there will be blood one night
I'm gonna come to you inside of your
house wherever you're sleeping and I'm
gonna cut your throat so this is another
flavor of vintage or early American
totally different from Gangs of New York
is just about buying all my tracks you I
love the way he seems to build the
accent and even the character around the
oral posture of course you do what you
do
he has his tongue bunched up in the
middle of his mouth and bracing against
the molars and he lets his cheeks be
very loose yes I do his mustache is also
perfect what else would I do with myself
English cockney accent Don Cheadle
Ocean's eleven hang on are you accusing
me a booby trap it there's no way the
actor was given enough time to prepare
oh yeah for example listen to this line
it'll be nice working with proper
villains again none of those bells
really hit their targets you had one job
to do conclusion look this stuff isn't
easy
good or bad these actors all took some
serious risks for our entertainment big
asterisk here when an accent doesn't go
right it's usually not the
actor's fault it's usually a combination
of actor coach and production and often
is about not having enough time to
prepare before shooting starts if
there's one thing to remember is that
accent is a crucial layer of
storytelling cool